hi I'm Charlize Theron and I play Lady
leso hi I'm Carrie Washington and I play
Professor dubby hi I'm Sophia Wiley and
I play Agatha hi I'm Sophia Ann Caruso
and I play Sophie and we're here with
BuzzFeed to play a game of Who's Who
[Music]
Sophia and colossal probably Caruso yeah
no you're just so like powerful and cool
like Sophia's an independent
foreign
[Music]
I guess so yeah I'm not necessarily like
super serious all the time and um I do
love a good baby pink moment so when I'm
supposed to be having these scenes with
Carrie and she's like showing all these
beautiful dresses to me inside I'm
wanting to scream of Joy but on the
outside I have to be like oh this is a
horrible so it's very difficult but um
so much fun too to play Someone So
Different
all right
oh I would say you no I would say you
you for sure I think it's a tie when I
get to work with other working moms it's
always it's like I was I weird on day
one I was like so tell me how do you do
it no okay I wasn't weird oh and I was
going off to do this big action movie
that I just finished so I was asking you
I promising like one question the whole
time yeah when you're a working mom
working with other working moms you
really feel like a kindred I tried to
share with those two and they just
blazed over yeah
no and you didn't go out and party yeah
exactly exactly
[Music]
a little like cereal party that one time
right yeah because none of them had ever
had an American candy so I got a bunch
of American candy and I threw a pajama
party where we all had to like
eat a bunch of candy it's the best kind
sounds like a chill party yeah this is
like a fun party it's a goofy
yeah
oh Wiley yeah yes
whoa no no no no thank you I take this
compliment and I give it back to the
three of you like literally every time
I'd have a scene with any of you guys I
was just in shock like it's so perfect
from the get-go and I'm like okay we can
as like I'm the director we can move on
like no like I don't have to say in any
of that do you not remember my first day
73 takes and we we maybe got it on 71.
we were both really impressed with you
both yeah I have to say yeah you were
but I mean we both were as we were
chatting about our children we were like
oh my God we better get our stuff
together yeah these girls are bringing
it you were both so clear about your
characters your choices were really
specific you understood the arc and
these were complicated arcs your
characters were transforming within the
film and you guys were just so on point
I don't know I'm pretty I'm pretty bad
at that I can I'll I'll like ruin it
take for sure I have I have no fourth
wall I have no acting skills whatsoever
I'm like an audience watching it I'm
just like that's the Oscar winner
we were definitely worse at that then
baby you guys were so immersed in your
characters I think we were like enjoying
it enjoying our characters a lot and
each other a lot yes
the two of you the two of you are like
musical theater phenoms she's literally
a Broadway star like I have to give that
to you Sophia there's like that's
amazing you guys got that yeah thank you
thank you yeah we should have a karaoke
night together we'll watch
I never really got to see these sweat
suits yeah I mean thanks to our costumes
but they were cute sweatsuits they were
like thank you yeah like nice sweat
suits not like you're always like
effortlessly chic
that like yes yes these costumes are
insanely good they're so fun so we all
got to look pretty amazing once we were
changed once we were transformed
oh I would love to wear charlize's
costumes I love suits I love wearing
suits I was kind of jealous yeah and I
would love to wear some of Carrie's
costumes like I think on the first day
I'd worked with Carrie she had this
beautiful gold dress on and it had that
like cool thing behind it it was almost
like a crown but it was like attached to
your back and it just like it was so so
elaborate and detailed and beautiful and
it fit like a glove and I was just like
that is a queen that's not even a
princess it's a full and queen actually
attached into her skin that's what she
does I tattooed it you look like it
they don't let us in the group chat
we're not allowed to be in the group
chat we're like did they eat like
because you don't have time for that I
feel like I sent some pretty funny memes
or at least I thought they were funny
but nobody would reply so maybe my meme
tastes just like a little too Niche
but you do such a good job at like
checking in like I think the the chat is
most active because you are like hey
guys how are you doing like just
checking in on everyone because it's so
hard since we don't all live in the same
place to really stay in contact so you
do a great job at that for sure thanks
jeez
I want to say Carrie I feel like Carrie
maybe Carrie will take a selfie do you
want to take one now I think you were
probably already did you're so fast
I always been like I don't want to not I
don't know she just always had access to
her phone on it's like somewhere in that
yeah it is I love those pictures too and
I look back at them it was such fun days
I have all these pictures with like that
iguana that you guys had in the school
for evil you're the lizard bearded
lizard did the bearded lizard poop on
you
it only poops like once every three
years what no I'm exaggerating but it's
pretty impressive
I'm gonna I'm gonna designate myself for
that one I don't know how much I think
you're like fairy tales probably I love
them like I've grown up on Disney fairy
tales my entire life and I I could do it
forever I think they're so entertaining
I'd take you on Wiley I'd battle you for
a fairy tale wisdom I think we should do
that I love that Carrie who's your
favorite like what's your favorite fairy
tale I mean my favorite musical of all
time is Into the Woods because it's like
every fairy tale you've ever wanted all
in one place and it's part of what I
love about our movie is that it's like
it brings so many of the stories that
you love into one
story
[Music]
oh I mean
yeah did you cry on the last day I feel
like we both cried but maybe I don't
know I I think we both did I think that
was just a really long day we were up in
like this contraption with these like
body casings like 20 feet above the
ground all day literally just so tired
whipped around as soon as they said
there was one of those crying tears of
joy because it was ready to get out of
the body cases yeah so bittersweet
because it was such a fun experience and
um meeting so many wonderful people
during that that period of time that we
were filming was was a true blessing and
having to say goodbye is always so sad
so it was like tears of joy and tears of
sadness too thank you so much for
playing with us make sure that you watch
the school for Good and Evil on Netflix
foreign
[Music]